- Oui, vraiment. On entend
de plus en plus, les enfants,
- C'est clair qu'on a remarqué
une montée des cas incblblble,
même si... Je pense que c'est d,
nous, en tant que citoyens,
puis aussi du gouvernement.
- Sommes-nous déjà en 6e vague?
à Québec : c'est bien le cas.
hehehez les experts, on constate
une chose : le train de la COVID
est, encore une fois, en marche.
Dr GASTON DE SERRES,
médecin épidémiologiste, INSPQ
- L'ensemble des indicateurs qui
étaient suivis pouveveveveveveve
vague, tous ces indicateurs-là
pointaient dans ecececection
d'une 6e vague.
- Mê
complètes depuis janvier,
plusieurs indicateurs tournent
maintenant rapidement au rouge.
Le nombre de cas confirmés
depuis une semaine
et le nombre de tests rapides
autodéeseseseseseseseseseseseset
sous-estimés.
d'excellence prévoit
également qu'au ryth
actuel des infections,
on pourrait s'attendre
à 200 hospitavrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvr.
Il faut dire que le nouveau
sous-variant Bgigigigigigigigig.
Il est presque 50 % plus
contagieux que son cousin
Omicron et produirait
deux fois plus importante,
selon une étude récente.
ROXANE BORGÈS DA SYLVA, dir.
École de santé publique, UdeM
- Une personne qui attrape
de 10 à 12 personnes dans
son entourage. C'est u
de reproduction qui est énorme
et qui s'appstststststststststss
maladies les plus contagieuses.
- Pour l'instant, dans le milieu
de la restauration, les dégâts
d'établissements fermés.Même cor
manufacturier, qui a tiré des
leçons de deux ans de pandémie.
VÉRONIQUE PROULX, Manufact
et exportateurs du Québec
- Mais c'est clair que
la préoccupation est là
vraiment quand même très
affectés, au cours des
deux dernières années, par
un taux d'absentéisme élevé
quand les gens étasisisisisisisn
n'évoluera pas trop rapidement.
- Maintenant qu'on a
une 6e vague, la recrudesc
inciter la santé publique
à réviser ses posit
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE, immunologue,
Institut de rech. clin. de Mtl
qu'on s'enligne pour
une prolongation de...
cette obligation de porter
les masques dans certains
contextes parce que je pen
le problème d'Omicron
ou de BA.2 va être
- Depuis une semaine, on a
observé une hausse de 16 %
des hospitalisations
Radio-Canada,